Good morning John, it’s question
Tuesday, the day that I answer
real questions from real
Nerdfighters.
And it’s not really
Tuesday, and it’s not really
going to be me.
Like the
Nerdfighters are real, the questions
are real, but am I real?
Shuffle is a podcast app, and
yes in thanks for doing this
I do have to say you should
check out their service, I
actually think it’d be pretty
cool if a lot of Nerdfighters
used it for Dear Hank & John
because you get to like
react and interact with the
podcast with other people
kind of.
So that might be cool.
But regardless, the point is
they have taken the tremendous
amount of transcripts of the
world you and I have said, John.
And they have created an AI
chat bot that is a mash up of
the two of us.
Which is something
else because sometimes you
can tell when it’s you and when it’s me.
And so I am doing a Question
Tuesday, but I’m not answering
the questions.
Artificial Hank
and John are.
Rachel asks,
what should I do about the
creeping dread?
Hmm… I would recommend that you try to do
the thing that you need to do to
reach those goals. Then turn
that into excitement because you’re
about to go for it.
I mean that
one was me.
That one’s definitely me.
It sounds like
good advice. Is it? Probably not.
Most of the stuff that
sounds like good advice isn’t.
Megan wants to know, do
you play minecraft?
Minecraft minecraft minecraft
minecraft minecraft.
How many socks are too
many socks?
I don’t know, 12.
This of all the things the
AI said I think is the most inaccurate.
I own a sock subscription
for charity, there’s no such thing
as too many socks.
You’re
challenged to a duel, what’s the
weapon?
Trampoline dodge ball. I mean, hell yeah.
That, yes.
Oat Milk Stan wants to know,
what do you recommend to
pass the time while I recover
from wisdom teeth removal?
I would recommend that if you
have wisdom teeth removed
recently, that watching Crash
Course videos at twice speed is
probably the best way to pass
the time.
Is it?
Like just after
anesthesia?
Did you mean half speed?
Chicken fingers dipped in applesauce
or French fries dipped in Frosty?
Definitely French fries dipped in
something because in something because
in any comparative tasting of applesauce or
French fries dipped in Frosty, the
French fries are going to win
every time.
I mean with a very tiny
exception that sounds like
exactly what I would say.
Is there a specific reason humans
get so attached to stuffed animals?
I think it’s natural selection.
I think that as we’ve evolved to be more
social we’ve sort of developed
the need for that attachment
through activities like filmmaking,
music, art-- still forms of
storytelling-- or you can tell a story.
We got a little lost at the end there
but that is a vlogbrothers vibe.
When eating a bicycle, where should one start?
I would venture to say
the handlebars first.
The spokes  might try to escape or rebel, and the
tire could explode.
That there feels very
uncanny valley to me.
It’s like it
thinks it knows what it’s like to be a
person but it actually doesn’t.
If you could turn one person into a
pelican who would it be and why?
I’d like to turn Prince Harry into a pelican
because he can dance like one.
I mean that’s funnier than anything I
would have said.
That’s funnier than
anything I would have said.
Favorite cursed item Nerdfighteria has
turned into a meme?
Oh god, I don’t know that we’ve
cursed any specific item.
We discovered the train song huh huh and we didn’t
realize that that was cursed, but it’s cursed.
I don’t know for sure what train
song the AI is talking about here,
but I’m pretty sure it’s this one.
All aboard the choo choo train, all aboard all aboard.
Did I discover that?
No. I kinda
rediscovered it though, and I like it
and it is also cursed.
Favorite social media platform?
I like Twitter a lot because I get
there first thing in the morning
and they blur the lines a bit between
what’s news and what’s not news.
That actually made me
feel a little bit too seen, AI bot.
Best pizza topping?
Not a day has gone by
when I haven’t thought wistfully of the
pepperocinis and mushroom pizzas
I used to eat while I lived in Ohio.
It remains in my brain as the perfect
marriage of pepperoni and fungus.
And that’s some hardcore
John Green vibes for you right there.
And let’s finish off with one from
Payton who asks, what is
your new furby’s name?
It’s not named yet, so the AI gets to do
it.
It’s Philip.
This has been delightful,
if a little unsettling.
I was having kind of a hard time
figuring out how to end this video.
But then I realized I could just turn to the AI.
John, wear sunscreen.
I’ll see you on Tuesday.